[Musique]
c'est tout simplement parce que c'est un
texte qui doit être vivant puisqu'il ya
une évolution à la fois des volontés
politiques sur le territoire et puis une
évolution regard réglementaire également
et donc il est nécessaire régulièrement
de revoir le texte
[Musique]
une évolution réglementaire pour se
mettre en conformité avec les nouvelles
lois sur l'environnement par exemple les
modifications apportées la vise
également à proposer cette
simplification et clarification des
règles édictées pour que les gens
puissent mieux s'en saisir il ya donc
une volonté collective de tous les
maires de protéger ses hameaux il ya
aussi tout ce qui touche aux franges
entre les zones urbaines et les zones
agricoles et là aussi il ya des efforts
que nous souhaitons faire nous sommes
encore dans la phase de discussion
puisque il y à une concertation très
importante qui doit se faire avec ce que
l'on appelle les personnes qualifiées
aux associés mais également les
habitants du territoire elle a démarré
en avril le 1er avril 2021 elle se
terminera début avril 2022
c'est ce qui touche en général le plus
les habitants sait quelles modifications
je peux apporter sur sur mon logement
nous avons des espaces verts et des
espaces que nous souhaitons protéger
important et c'est l'un des objectifs de
cette modification nous avons aussi des
des lieux que nous considérons comme
emblématiques ou en tout cas intéressant
à protéger